if you like spectator TV do subscribe to
our YouTube channel spectator TV is
picking up thousands of new subscribers
every week and you should be one of them
just click the Subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and tap the Bell
icon so you never miss an episode
first up Douglas Moyer writes about
George Osborne's plan to return the
Elgin marbles to Greece in this week's
magazine why is it that more and more
Museum directors seem to hate the
collections they're looking after
Douglas joins me now
Douglas thank you for joining us on
spectator TV you're out in the magazine
this week about a particular Affliction
that seems to affect tourism middle age
and how you always suspected George
Osborne was going to succumb to it so uh
can you tell us a bit about that please
and why why you think George Osborne was
a prime candidate for a midlife crisis
yes it's a fascinating uh part of
political anthropology that there is a
type of conservative particularly
conservative male it has to be said who
in middle age has a sort of breakdown
about their beliefs and uh I know see
also met Hancock
um and uh usually they this expresses
itself in a loss of belief in the things
that they have argued for hitherto and
usually the adoption of a
um right on cause as they see it
ordinarily it manifests in uh requests
or the legalization of marijuana or
drugs of some kind
um and that's the most common one
um Crispin blunt this is a good example
as well
um and the I think the explanation is
the certain type of conservative has
been so used to espousing relatively
unpopular or uncool opinion that they
hope that if they do something sort of
Grand in middle age it'll make up for it
and wash all of these sins away I say
that George Osborne has long been a
prime candidate for this
um George Osborne of course gets all of
the attacks and brick backs of the left
I think rather unfairly I mean they
literally accuse him being a murderer uh
of killing people through austerity
which of course was was not really
austerity at all but anyway he he
suffered a lot of unpopularity perhaps
culminating in that famous Boo in the
stadium in the London Olympics which
must have been very uh uh upsetting to
it uh but I I predicted that that he
would be the sort of conservative who
who would end up having a midlife crisis
and he would have to espouse some right
on cause and the moment that he took
over as chair uh chairman of the
trustees of the British museum I thought
ah I see this one coming
he's arranged so this is manifested he's
arranged alone for the Elgin marbles can
you tell us a bit about that why is it
such a bad deal for example to give the
Greeks the Elgin marbles for a little
while uh well I mean first of all as I
say it's a totally predictable thing uh
if you become a chair of the trustees
the British Museum and your conservative
uh you will feel disproportionate uh
desire to send the Elgin Marble uh to
Greece uh it would it would it's so
tempting uh as this wonderful
demonstration of right hollery
um and of course George Osborne we've
learned has been uh negotiating this
return I I say that
um in the in the magazine I say I think
it's a rather unwise uh deal a deal
that's so cat-handed in fact so far as
we know that it could have been
negotiated by an Austin Powers villain
um it's it it's it's apparently a deal
that that the British museum sends uh
the marbles uh to Athens and in return
Athens sends some Treasures that have
never before been seen in uh the UK
um that's very nice of them I'm sure but
I would have thought that it's the
likelihood of the marbles being returned
is exceptionally small as Noel Malcolm
of uh or Souls among others has said
this week it would only require one
Greek citizen to go to court and insist
marbles must not be returned to the UK
and um that would hold it up on its own
and goodness knows that person might
even find the Greek courts are slightly
sympathetic to their case uh so um it
isn't a very wise uh a deal it seems to
me and although people deny it uh
there's just no doubt that when it comes
to this alleged returning of treasures
um you start off with one and you go
straight on to the other uh the Benin
bronzes have long been uh or at least
for some years have been regarded as
sort of stolen loot which most of them
are not uh and uh the obar of Benin has
been getting more press recently than at
any time since the late 19th century and
the billion bronzes will of course be
next and then you just go down down the
list uh there's a call through Egypt for
the Rosetta Stone to be sent there
um it just won't end and as I say it's
it's a demonstration of of a type of
weakness but a type of weakness that
really only the Tory male in midlife is
capable of
and you mentioned the piece as well
Douglas that all this seems to be going
on there's some sort of obsession with
giving the marbles back and decolonizing
the museum comes at a time when the
British museum is facing a bit of a
crisis in terms of the theft of yes
missing items do you think they've been
distracted essentially from their main
functions yes that's right I'm uh almost
2 000 artifacts appear to have been uh
um stolen from the British museum under
the noses of of the director and
trustees it's extraordinary uh a member
of Staff has been fired and and the
Museum's director has resigned
um but we've subsequently learned that
even two years ago a Danish expert wrote
to the British museum saying that
artifacts from the British museum were
finding their way into onto the market
even being put on eBay and so having
been alerted to this two years ago the
British museum appears not to have acted
at all and thought that actually
everything was fine I wonder if this
isn't the time to extend one of my own
laws I might histrionically call it
Murray's law
which is this in the same way that we
now know that when a an energy company
goes on about how green they are we know
that they're polluters
um and in the same way that we now know
that when a bank goes sort of huge on
BLM or something they're actually
corrupt or that when a financial
services uh firm decides to go huge on
ESG Dei and all the other stuff it's
because they're not giving good returns
to their customers we should I think
start to assume that when museums like
the British museum end up obsessing over
their their collection as if they're
stolen goods actually they are not in
charge of the collection in the way they
should be actually they are not
protecting and preserving The Collection
which is after all their sole job I
think we should expect
in such cases the moment that a museum
director or curator starts talking about
getting rid of the collection is if it's
a set of hot stolen goods off the back
of a truck we should assume that they
actually do not have the ability to do
the basics of looking after the core of
the collection yeah I mean see you
mentioned the museum director there
who's who's recently resigned I mean he
was behind moving the bust of Han Sloan
from a different part of the museum
because it was linked to the slave trade
I mean do you ever get the sense of why
do these people in particular take these
jobs if they resent their collections so
much
you're so right I mean exactly the the
um the the director who did that of
course you know
totally tokenistic and pointless and
actually rather insulting uh gestures
like the movement of the of the bust uh
become a sort of cover as I say for sort
of inadequacies at best uh elsewhere I
think you can see this in collection
after collection I've written about this
in the magazine before most obvious
example is the welcome trust but I would
I would I would suggest that people
should do a serious audit on the
governance of Tate uh Britain among
others I've written about this in the
magazine before but Tate Britain uh is
is run by people who seem to hate the
collection in their care and keep
insulting the artists whose work they
are in they are meant to be preserving
for future Generations most notably uh
Tate written has been uh has closed the
Rex Whistler mural room insulted Rex
Whistler who died fighting the Nazis
um also insulted Stanley Spencer and
degraded him as some kind of racist I
think that all all of the people in
charge of the collection of tape written
should be should be fired I think they
have no right to be in charge of a great
National Collection but that's that's
the difference that seems to exist today
there was a period where to be on a
board like that of Tate of Britain was
to know that you had a guardianship for
a short time of one of the great
collections in the country and indeed in
the world it takes a certain type of
extraordinary uh what would you call it
um not just hubris but a kind of
arrogance to think to dare to think that
your job is not to preserve the
collection but to stand in judgment over
that's that's a stand in judgment over
how it was put together and who
contributed to it and who the artists
are and whether or not they live up to
your glorious self
um to hell with these people uh they
they have no right to be in charge of
our great collections many of them
clearly demonstrably uh uh unfit for the
task
um and I and I I had any upright would
like to see them replaced uh by people
who actually venerate the collections
and regard it as being an honor as it is
to be in charge of such Treasures
brilliant thank you very much Douglas
[Music]
foreign